Traductor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Javi Garriz
A ver si puedo explicar
lo que quería explicar:
Hace 8 años tuve un derrame,
bueno, una lesión primero.
El médico me dijo: "Mira, Olivia,
si quieres te lo voy a explicar,
tú tienes una lesión desde pequeña,
pero sería como si tuvieras un tigre.
Ese tigre ha estado
40 años durmiendo,
no te ha dado ningún problema,
no tenías idea de que estaba aquí.
Ahora resulta que se ha despertado
y te ha dado un pequeño "susto".
Yo que tú, habría que matarlo."
Para eso preparamos una operación.
Una operación que no fue
muy bien, la verdad,
y me levanté con la parte
derecha inmovilizada
y con un problema de lenguaje.
Me desperté sin poder
escribir ni hablar nada,
porque tenía la enfermedad de afasia.
La afasia es una enfermedad muy rara,
porque la gente que la tiene
tiene problemas de lenguaje,
entonces nadie habla de esa enfermedad.
(Risas)
Eso es lo que pasa.
Y además esa gente está en su casa,
no puede hablar con sus amigos,
y cada vez [más] se van cerrando,
cerrando, cerrando,
y es una enfermedad dura por eso,
no te duele nada, no tienes nada,
pero no lo puedes explicar.
¿Cómo le pasa a mi cerebro?
¿Cómo funciona?
Para mí, porque hay afasias
de cualquier [tipo].
En mi cerebro, por ejemplo...
Vosotros cuando habláis,
vais de una idea a otra y a otra:
"Esta mañana he ido a una charla
que ha estado muy bien, y no sé qué,
pero esta tarde
tengo que ir a no sé cuanto..."
Y vais de una idea
a la otra y la otra,
de A a B a C, por autopistas,
rápido, rápido.
En nuestro caso, bueno,
en este caso, en el mío,
yo no tengo autopistas.
Yo tengo una carretera nacional, o local,
y además es de noche, y está lloviendo,
además han caído unas piedras,
ha habido un terremoto, un tsunami,
y al final, llego a la idea B.
La 3, no tengo ni idea de qué
quería decir, evidentemente.
Además es como si fuera...
También me lo imagino
como si fuera [así]:
vosotros habláis rápido, normalmente,
y no pensáis que todo eso
lo estáis explicando con palabras,
y para eso [hay] alguien detrás
de nuestro cerebro que elige las palabras,
porque estamos tan concentrados
en lo que queremos explicar,
que no te das cuenta de que tienes
que utilizar el "de", el "te",
el tiempo verbal...
Y eso es que [hay alguien]
detrás, dentro, que...
está haciendo un trabajo
sin que nadie lo vea.
Es como un mayordomo, que además sabe
dónde están los cajones de tus palabras,
y además te lo pone como en una bandeja,
te lo pone en la boca y salen para ti,
y tú además haces un discurso
que a veces hasta es bonito e inteligente,
y tú no has hecho nada.
En mi caso, mi mayordomo
se ha ido de vacaciones o no está,
o se ha ido de huelga,
porque yo no tengo nada,
y entonces cada vez que hablo,
tengo que concentrarme -como ahora mismo-
en qué palabra tengo que decir,
no solo las palabras,
sino "tengo-que-decir."
Bastante complicado.
Otra manera más fácil que dijo mi hija.
Decía: "Mira, todos tenemos las palabras
en el cerebro y las sacamos por la boca,
[entre ambos] hay una cuerda,
y a mi madre se la ha roto.
El médico ha hecho un nudo
y ella tiene que aprender a hablar".
Yo antes trabajaba en TV3
como realizadora.
Evidentemente... lo importante para mí
era la comunicación,
y evidentemente ahora no podía hacerlo.
Yo siempre llevaba
un diario encima, con ideas,
bueno, no tanto un diario
de "mi novio me ha dejado" o algo así,
[escribía] ideas que me gustaban,
cosas que me interesaban, proyectos...
este era mi diario normalmente, cada día.
Cuando me desperté estaba en...
-¡en el sofá, iba a decir!-
(Ríe)
en la cama,
inmovilizada,
Intenté volver a escribir y esta es
la primera [vez] que intentaba escribir.
Lo comparas y es bastante "heavy", ¿no?
Pero bueno, no pasa nada,
no es una historia de dramas,
no pasa nada, porque de esto
hace ocho años.
En estos ocho años he mejorado un poco,
he hecho muchos,
muchos ejercicios y ejercicios,
incluso he editado un libro,
y un libro bonito, además.
(Risas)
Pero ahí estoy.
Además la logopeda me han ayudado mucho.
Dos años después de estar con ella,
me dijo: "Mira, Olivia,
tienes que intentar ir a la vida real,
porque eso no tiene nada que ver
con los ejercicios,
tú puedes estar en casa haciendo
ejercicios y más ejercicios,
pero la vida no tiene nada que ver.
Yo [me agarraba a] sus piernas:
"¡Yo no quiero ir, no quiero ir!"
"Sí, Olivia, para afuera".
Y realmente es muy duro
y muy raro [salir] a la vida.
¿Cómo puede ser la vida para una afásica?
Bueno, en mi caso,
yo, por ejemplo,
me hago un lío, realmente.
Hace dos años dije:
"Ahora quiero hacer un diario",
lo voy a intentar.
No para escribir, sino con pegatinas,
papeles o dibujos.
Hace dos años me compré
una libreta nueva, bonita, muy guay.
Primera página:
Voy con mi hijo al... zoo,
me voy a casa a pegar [la entrada]
y veo, por primera vez:
"Una persona discapacitada"
y un tigre que me mira.
Eso es el resumen de cómo era yo,
de cómo es mi vida,
mi vida es así: con un tigre en mi cabeza
y además tengo discapacidad.
¿Y cómo vive una mujer... sin lenguaje?
Pues es un poco complicado.
Porque yo, por ejemplo,
mi cabeza va como...
Como vamos tan rápidos... te vas
a comprar algo, por ejemplo a una tienda.
Yo la última vez fui a una pescadería,
y quiero sardinas.
Y entonces me dicen: "¿Sardinas cómo?"
Y en vez de decirle: "Sardinas pequeñas
o grandes", dices "azules".
"¿Cómo que sardinas azules?"
(Risas)
Y claro, tú estás buscando... ¡Un momento,
que quiero saber el cajón,
dónde está el cajón de "azul",
de "pequeñas" o "grandes"!
pero me ha salido por ahí.
O por ejemplo, me dicen...
claro, es que estás con las personas
y no saben que eres afásica.
Mis hijos me entienden.
Por ejemplo, cuando les dices: "Va, ponte
los cereales, que nos vamos al cole",
y él ya sabe que quieres
decir "los calcetines",
pero ya no dice nada, y es igual,
porque yo estoy midiendo:
¿Calcetines? Calcetines, calcetines...
con c... ceram... varias sílabas...
Es como en Google o Whatsapp,
que te acaba las palabras,
tú lo entras [la palabra]
y dices: "Vale, calcetines"
(Risas y aplausos)
Luego están los números.
Lo de los números es un poco "heavy",
no sabía cuántas veces te preguntan
el DNI en la vida real.
(Risas)
Te lo piden para todo,
por ejemplo para venir aquí: DNI.
Conclusión, yo ya no tengo
ninguna... cartera,
porque me hace un lío
saber dónde está el DNI,
y tienes que traer el carnet
y te miran como [diciendo]:
"Pobrecilla, no se sabe ni el número".
Por ejemplo, a veces me llaman a casa:
"¿Olivia? Un paquete de Correos".
Y yo: "Oh, no, ahora va a pedir el DNI,
¿dónde está mi cartera?"
Voy a buscarla...
y llega él y dice: "¿Olivia?"
Y digo: "No, soy la mujer de la limpieza".
-¿El nombre?
-Nancy.
(Risas)
"¿DNI?" ¡Me lo invento!
Firmas, cierras y dices: ¡Guay!
(Risas y aplausos)
Hay momentos en los que también
sale algo de luz en tu cerebro.
Por ejemplo, yo he nacido
en Barcelona, claro.
Bueno, "claro" no...
(Risas)
he nacido en Barcelona,
y hablo en dos idiomas,
pero la logopeda me dijo:
"Olivia, vamos a empezar por uno".
(Risas)
Como mis padres eran castellanohablantes,
así que, vale, castellano.
Pero a veces me sale un poco,
yo sé que ahí está el catalán.
Ya está, no pasa nada, estará...
Está ahí.
Por ejemplo, voy a una tienda, me empiezan
a explicar cosas, yo le contesto,
"¿Qué quería?, ¿y cuándo?"
Una conversación no filosófica,
digamos, ni muy larga.
Pero sales de la tienda y dices:
"¡Ostras, pero si he hablado en catalán,
cómo es posible!"
Solo una vez me ha salido,
también es verdad, pero bueno.
(Risas)
Pero yo sé que la idea está ahí.
Yo si busco, igual me lo encuentro.
Lo que siempre encuentro es la enfermedad.
La enfermedad está siempre presente.
Y la enfermedad no me ha servido
para nada, odio la enfermedad,
no me hace mejor persona para nada.
No me sale salir ahora y decir:
"¡Oh, qué día más bonito, gracias!"
Porque no, no me ayudado nada de nada,
odio la enfermedad.
(Aplausos)
Incluso lo que es peor todavía
es la autoayuda,
que a mí no me ha ayudado, pero bueno.
Hay gente a la que si le gusta,
si le ayuda, muy bien.
Pero a mí no me ha gustado.
A lo mejor a mi familia o a mis amigas
les hubiera [ayudado]
tener un libro que pusiera:
"Cómo ser amiga de una afásica",
borde, además, porque
las afásicas son bordes,
porque estamos ahorrando
palabras, todo el rato,
(Risas)
si tú normalmente preguntas: "¿Me puede
dar un vaso de agua, por favor?"
Tú vas y dices: "¡Agua!"
(Risas)
Es verdad, somos bordes.
Bordes, pero no tontas,
que es una cosa que ya me dijo
mi logopeda Esther, que es muy lista:
"Cada día, te tienes que repetir
'No soy tonta, no soy tonta'",
porque es muy complicado no ser tonta
si no sabes el DNI,
no sabes decir una cosa,
no puedes explicar nada...
Realmente te da la sensación de ser tonta.
Tonta, y veces yo incluso puedo pensar
que podemos ser un poco listas,
porque cuando no hablas,
como no tienes que hablar,
porque no tienes las soluciones,
porque como todo es tan rápido,
pues no llegas, y entonces te callas.
Y te pones a... escuchar y a escuchar...
y ves cosas interesantes,
escuchar está muy bien,
porque ves las cosas diferentes,
porque ves a gente que es
un poco... chulo o tonto.
Ves cosas, porque antes estabas pensando
tu solución... en la conversación,
ahora ya no, ese papel te lo quitas.
Y con la gente que no te conoce,
como no hablas,
pasas a ser: "Qué interesante esa chica".
(Risas)
Tienes un aire,
que dicen: "Qué guay esa chica".
Y con los amigos, como no trabajas,
y como escuchas, te llaman,
y quedas con más gente para hablar.
(Risas)
Y como esa gente se olvida
de que estás enferma,
te hablan y dicen: "Ay, chica,
qué bien escuchas,
(Risas)
qué atenta".
Bueno, gracias a todos.
Como vosotros habéis hecho...
Yo os recomiendo escuchar, que está bien,
porque vosotros aprenderéis más,
y vuestros amigos os darán las gracias.
Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)